here's one that you love if it's magic i
got to do this song
for him yeah for uh for a benefit
years ago oh man is that intimidating
stevie wonder is like
i mean a ridiculous genius what is that
like to sing
a guy's song for him
it wasn't she was crazy well i mean it
was crazy because like i remember
so i was a kid dude and i was like
living at the chateau and i was like
[ __ ] nuts and and you know couldn't
be bothered to do anything and then
they're like stevie wants to do this
thing for him i'm like cool
we're gonna do if it's magic great
that's a quiet song
you're left very exposed like it's your
voice in a
room full of people and stevie wonder's
sitting there
everything is coming in now and you're
gonna have to be exposed to that so
yes it was the scariest moment really
yeah cause that was that was like oh
[ __ ] like here we go and he's just
staring you know he's not staring
obviously but he's like he's there and
he's like
feeling you and you better you better
deliver this and it's funny because it
was
you could hear a pin drop i'll never
forget that moment because viveka a fox
introduced me and it was quiet it was
just
it was the keyboard intro and i'm out
there and i'm looking
dead into steve like i'm right there and
i'm like okay here we go and he comes in
and i start singing
and right as i started singing there was
a woman
in the audience and just goes like you
go boy like the sun
that always shines
and i'm like okay i was like all right
it's gonna be okay it's gonna be okay
and by the way it's also a very
confidence boosting thing to have
stevie be the person that wanted me to
do this in the first place
and i stayed with him before that too
which is cool oh did you is that how you
met him you were singing with him we did
remember the live eight concert
yeah oh yeah we did the live eight thing
and stevie was like hey
they want to do stevie wants to sing
with you i'm like no [ __ ] okay
and i remember what our rehearsal was
like which would you laugh because
it was me meeting stevie he gave me this
giant hug
this big bear hug right just held on to
me and he
and he whispers in me and he's like all
right so you're gonna do lack of fool
but because we're singing uh we're
singing sign seal delivered right
and i have i've been listening to the
motown like the record like i'm just
like i've been okay i wonder what part
he'll have me do like this is the day of
show now no sound check nothing
and he's like you're gonna do like a
fool uh you got the first he's telling
me all the [ __ ] i'm gonna do
and he's hugging me and i'm like okay
like it sounds good
no rehearsals and and no rehearsal so
i'm [ __ ] petrified i'm like 23
24 or whatever oh my god here we go a
million people stevie wonder and he
called me up and i'll never forget
hearing him call me up so it's like adam
levine
come out here and i didn't move
like i was like frozen on the side of
the stage and my tour manager
had to push me out so if you watch it
it's funny every once in a while i'll
trip out on that and watch it
you see me running to the mic because
i'm about to miss the
verse and i still [ __ ] the words up i
think i still messed up the verse
because running out there you even lose
your breath and all of singing is breath
control yeah i was like like a fool i
wasn't staying too long and
um
you [ __ ] it up i [ __ ] it up